une ovation aux sports dans le sport
avec vous oui c'est bien sûr je suis un
sport pour ceux qui ont mal vu tout
assumer dans le sport je suis mis dans
le sport on va continuer à rester et on
va rester attrape un avec le
traditionnel tournoi international de
judo organisé par le bushido club de
trappes et pour en parler avec nous ce
soir sur ce plateau la présidente du
bushido club mari ahmed bonsoir bonsoir
et vous êtes accompagné de philippe
pactole birac fort soir professeur en
formation du torch un bon soir bonsoir
20e édition 20e 20e anniversaire qu'est
ce qui fait le succès du tournoi
alors je vais commencer bonsoir à vous
et merci de nous recevoir alors
qu'est-ce qui fait ce succès ben voilà
c'est notre déjà notre label que nous
avons depuis la 4ème année donc qui fait
une qualité
pour ce tournoi international et qui
donne
une image sur trappe qui nous fait voir
que ben voilà on donne du beau judo et
que ça fait venir nos contacts dans le
compétiteur vous parler de la belle
alors le label g voilà le label b c'est
une pour les jeunes les seniors et les
juniors qui donne des points pour
l'obtention de la ceinture noire et qui
nous donne une prestance
vraiment pour une bonne qualité de
tournoi international et on vous parle
et on international puisque outre les
équipes françaises traditionnelles et
régionales il y à des étrangers qui
viennent à alger une délégation
algérienne
c'est tout frais ou bien de savoir
qu'ils ont eu leur l'obtention du visa
donc est arrivé ce matin donc je les ai
eus au téléphone ils arrivent le 15 ou
le 16 novembre pour le pour ce tournoi
nous avons une délégation belge une
délégation hollandaise et
nos mauriciens pour la première fois
l'humoriste qui sont déjà sur en france
qui parcourt un peu les compétitions
avec dix bons compétiteurs dans leur
équipe 1500 combattants vont s'affronter
sur sur les tatamis ça mais ça nécessite
deux jours de compétition de 7 heures le
matin à 9 heures la très tard le soir
oui voilà malheureusement très tard le
soir si on pouvait faire nocturne ça
serait pas mal on pourrait mais voilà
c'est une fois falloir qu'on gère et le
bushido club de trappes engage des
combattants seniors en jeunes oui nous
avons une dizaine de une dizaine de
jeunes
plutôt des minimes et des benjamins ces
quatre tranches d'âge
benjamin les benjamins s'affaisse 10 11
ans et 13 13 14 ce sont des jeunes qui
ont déjà fait des compétitions on va
dire de renommée nationale ou autre oui
oui oui ce sont des jeunes qui
commencent à évoluer au niveau du judo
et qui vont voir par rapport au tour
noire conscience est passé fois donc il
commence un peu déjà à sentir cette
c'est ce goût à la compétition tout à
fait et au niveau des inscriptions 1500
combattants c'est c'est énorme cdc
fermer ses bouquets ça y est vous avez
vous refusé du monde comme chaque année
je présume nous avons normalement les
inscriptions alors il faut savoir que
les inscriptions se font par la
fédération de judo donc
c'était jusqu'au 5 novembre nous avons
été obligés d'arrêter vos trente 30 au
31 octobre à la demande de notre
directeur technique monsieur michel roux
parce que on était surbooké l'autre au
delà du label il ya aussi des points je
ne sais pas pour des points pour la
coupe de france ou genre de cinar pour
d'autres événements internationaux non
non c'est uniquement pour l'abstention
de la ceinture vous qui êtes professeur
presque trappe à des bonnes chances
aussi sur cette compétition au niveau de
mes élèves ils ont des noms des noms
quels sont les jeunes qui va falloir
suivre du club de trappes
donc il ya un mine
hamlin droit fille qui est cadet donc
vraiment le suivent pas ce qu'il est en
train d'évoluer très bien en ce moment
donc il ya que lui en ce moment dans
tous les autres commencent à venir petit
à petit
conservation sur ses élèves pour voir
comment vous allez suivre tout au long
du week-end pour voir leur comportement
sur sur le tatami tout à fait très bien
épreuve importante c'est lors de ces
rendez vous là qu'on voit si justement
il ya une âme de compétiteur dans ses
gènes oui c'est en discussion technique
dans ces types de compétition qu'on peut
voir qu'ils vont avoir de l'avenir au
plus tard ces jeunes là c'est des jeunes
que vous avez sélectionné auparavant où
ils vous ont dit non j'ai envie de faire
de la compétition je veux m'y mettre
donc il ya certaines jeunes qui veut
faire la compulsion donc on les prépare
pour pouvoir qu'ils puissent bien bien
commencé et par la suite si ça leur
plaît ils continuent leur chemin
l'aspect compétition c'est une priorité
à trappes non non non du tout il ya eu
aussi du loisir c'est plus la formation
sait tout sur la formation voilà qu'on
ne force quiconque à faire de la
compétition s'il le désire on les paie
pas mais sinon qu'ils sont là que le
brasseur
alors il ya eu les jeux olympiques cet
été ce qui a eu un effet un effet yoyo
avec les superbes performances de teddy
riner lucie décosse vous avez vu des
petits jeunes arriver et dire je veux
faire comme teddy le carton réussi oui
surtout surtout sur les petits puisque
nous les prenons à partir de 4 ans donc
c'est ce qu'on appelle le baby judo donc
c'est l'initiation et c'est surtout là
que les enfants vu alors moi je veux
faire du judo enfin bon voilà c'était
parce que cette fois ci
il ya du potentiel sa vie chez les
tout-petits ya quatre ans où il était
oui d'ailleurs nous avons un gros un
grand potentiel nous avons d'haïti qui
était 7e aux championnats d'europe donc
malheureusement est là il est blessé
alors il va pas combattre au tournoi
légalement il a 15 ans 15 ans d'accord
et il va venir entend bénévoles arbitres
et donc pour nous il y aurait été super
d'être là en compétiteur mais
malheureusement il était à trappes
pendant cinq ans là il est parti à
argenteuil merci à tous les deux être
venu anthony un petit rappel sur ce
rendez vous ça commence quand ça c'est
vraiment ce samedi matin à partir de 7
heures 30 les premières peser jusqu'à
dimanche 18h on a le temps finit à 18
heures ça sera bien pour le wild en tout
le week-end pour venir voir quelques
combats bien sûr avec plaisir messieurs